[Music]
in the Tata based tender news da de da
de da de base she i was just wiegel
workers submitted by third-degree burns
[Music]
a former cop allegedly used law
enforcement databases as a personal
dating service what wait isn't that the
worst way to get like come get a girl
with a fever II don't even want to date
anyone in that database in the system
yeah because they have a low self-esteem
uses like maybe he looks at all the
police arrests did you like she's fine
she's hot oh she's not that good at
least you know how tall we are looking
at mug shot yeah yeah I think so I think
so too
so the department so six this takes
place in Florida I wouldn't be surprised
that there's hot girls that get arrested
and they were bad Oh Miami Beach yeah
there's hookers there the police
department said that they have reached
out to as many as 150 women Oh during
their investigation because this cop
former officer named lil Nez
my name is he targeted mainly Hispanic
women and so he finished his position to
approach them for dates and he even he
may have had sex with some of them while
on duty and so he got caught because he
followed this woman it must have been so
funny if he's like on duty he has his
[ __ ] vest on he has the belt with all
his like the gun and all that and then
he's trying to [ __ ] um but he's like
trying to take this [ __ ] off and it's
taking like 20 minutes and [ __ ] that
might be really awful the holster I
don't want to get shot right you know
like on accident just get shot down
there and get shot in the leg shot in
the arm shot head neck who knows
you just get you keep it in the holster
it's not gonna shoot anybody yeah keep
it on holster
some girl ratted on Emma well so this so
this officer he follows so he met this
woman in a parking lot at a local store
and then he followed her home in his
police car he'd knocked on her door but
it was her parents house and then he
told them that he wanted to speak with
their daughter about a domestic
the parents refused oh good
asked for his name and his supervisors
information and then this officer left
and then so the woman's parents called
the police department and told them that
the officer was on duty at time on duty
at the time and then when the watch
commander asked the officer what
happened he said that he followed the
woman home because she had a headlight
out and so obviously the two stories
didn't match
and then so they ordered an
investigation and then Wow
yeah and then I'm so rare internal
affairs they probably didn't like him
yeah they're like I have a suspicion
that he's raping women so I want to
catch this [ __ ] like he's creepy and
nobody liked him and I mean he must not
have a lot of friends at the station cuz
he's just sitting on the computer
jerking off the girls that he doesn't
know he must be that guy that just keeps
making those really uncomfortable sexual
jokes in the weight loss it exists like
in almost every office if you want to
[ __ ] smash that [ __ ] right yes so
then when those dogs happen I just stare
at them like that just dead stare don't
even like give him a grin like don't
even be like yeah homie just like stare
at them I was feel really uncomfortable
when a guy does that [ __ ] it's like why
and we don't even have that type of
rapport no so why would you do that with
me are you doing you know guys are so
stupid yeah definitely in that case
really you like [ __ ] all the big [ __ ]
with a little [ __ ] y'all not [ __ ] man
that's why they talk about no Mikey I
have like a whole day I have like an
older lady that tried to like relate to
me and I'm arrested something and she
was like like sex toys and I was like no
[ __ ] what no absolutely not no and like
do I want to talk about six hours of you
and you're just talking about what you
need for lunch it was so weird I said I
was like an ID donor for two days it was
at the new job but almost like worked Oh
Lord if she's horny we're talking about
those guys that you guys were talking
about it reminds me of that one dude
that Gina posted on her Twitter Oh
not explain that situation explain it
because I'm not very good okay Gina has
this obsession with a guy that looks
like a closeted gay dude but he loves to
front but he is so delusional he has no
idea how lame he is and then let me
first start off by explaining what this
guy looks like okay he's the kind of guy
that gets the type of a design on his
[ __ ] beard with the [ __ ] circles
swirls in the swirls
he likes to pluck his eyebrows and
they're really thick eyebrows they're
thick but he has this Prince look to him
she sent this in whole space he's very
flamboyant so it's like you're a little
too overweight to be wearing that type
deep v-neck shirt but he does that
anyway
he feels good not a guy that looks like
he would wear affliction in ed hardy
he's the kind of guy that seems like he
will go to Hot Topic and by all the
trendiest things and put it on his car
but he's also the kind of guy that likes
to pretend like he's rich and he [ __ ]
[ __ ] non-stop non-stop according to
him yep according to him make sure you
shave your [ __ ] because I don't like
eating that [ __ ] like nobody invited you
to eat any [ __ ] oh is that what he said
yes because there was no like voice
changed no tone chains and I was like
David where did that come but that is
exactly that's like the type of [ __ ] he
would say he's the kind of guy that will
go to like a regular takeout sushi place
and take a picture of that and be like
yo sushi everyday that's all about gonna
say something about like your waitress
fishes just like the [ __ ] it'll be like
that too it would be creepy
it's really weird weirdo anyway back to
this officer here so once they started
investigating they searched his use of
States driver and vehicle information
database and they found that several
hundred of his search inquiries in the
department's database were it diverged
that's good
from the open and active case
this and it was a very very clear trend
of focusing on female versus male names
this guy would be a perfect target for
the mob if they just send one of their
lady mobsters oh yeah like be the sex
pot and then like the honey pot or
whatever and then lure him in oh and yup
they have an inside guy now he needs the
police database incognito window of fame
he didn't know about that huh uh-huh he
don't even know yeah so he used the
database information to reach out to the
women with social media phone calls and
visits to their homes to try to get
dates with them imagine a police officer
deeming you an Instagram is saying
you've been a bad bad girl Teresa lega
what do you say back to that officer do
you need me to come in I'm gonna report
you you know yeah like how does that
conversation started this hundred
percent makes sense why the parents
called the police when he showed up
because if he looked like this disguise
he showed up probably smiling a little
bit need to talk to your daughter better
why does he look like a 22 year old it's
like Manny from that one show Jay you
know that [ __ ] that [ __ ] show with
Ella
Al Bundy he has a new show oh my god
yeah he should have just been a normal
cop and jumped out of a birthday cake
and started dancing mm-hmm a normal guy
you know like off-duty cops they do it
all the time you know they do the police
work and then at night they do birthday
parties I think we dude you're such a
[ __ ] dweeb
yeah what he was on the force for 12
years loser piece of [ __ ] they pulled
him from patrol duty placed on
administrative leave without pay
stripped him of his badge gonna wanna
for [ __ ] he ended up resigning dope
and they're saying that if he
resigned huge definitely would have been
fired and as of now the investigation is
still ongoing but they're saying that he
could be subjected to criminal charges
what is he gonna do for living now he's
definitely that dude in that when
everybody's having lunch and just talks
about the girl that he's [ __ ] or
something you know y'all [ __ ] [ __ ]
this girl the other night you want to
see his picture look at her she's
[ __ ] hot right yeah did I [ __ ]
banger or you sounds like creepy stuff
to feel it out and see if there's any
other guys in the force that are like
him that like you know or creep it on
girls like yeah I saw this girl the
other day pull her over she's pretty hot
you pulling buddy it's always like an
uncomfortable situation that you don't
even know this dude we got times you
shut the [ __ ] up bro do you get the [ __ ]
away from Gerald gerald
relax Pedro it's especially weird when
you have no report
yeah we're just like seeing the same hot
girl and I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
that's different because we're friends
exactly and you built that like
connection or rapport and then it's like
it's different when it's like somebody
completely different like hey you won't
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you don't know you like
that homey food especially when they
look like that yeah we're talking about
how we should have cops you know past
that physical duty but who the [ __ ] are
you gonna arrest and look at little ass
shoulders you know I honestly got no
shoulders dude like I honestly think
that the parents thought that one his
approach was weird and they probably
thought he wasn't a real cop oh dude
I'll cop and be like this is a dude
that's in a suit and I'm like what okay
what's your supervisors name call up
there find out that's really super I'm
like okay this is what your boy did
that's why they call like my daughter's
too fine for your ass that's too fine
for your ass dude get the [ __ ] out of
here man that's done he's so gross
because before I thought I was like a
confident cop walking up the steps
dude how do you speak your daughter a
bit of domestic whatever case and I'm
like oh [ __ ] down the pants are really
bald but if this guy was like
guys make their dollars the messy case
yeah I could see the pants going guy
that just sits there buddy breathe love
like the nest the mouth-breather that
used to be me no you weren't a [ __ ]
loud breather I wasn't no this guy is
allowed
[Music]
[Music]